Traduttore: Emanuele Francesco Pecora
Revisore: francesca bornatici
In molti mi chiedono
perché vivo ancora in Sicilia.
A generare uno strano effetto
non è solo il fatto
che un bambino siciliano
abbia deciso di vocare
la propria vita al jazz,
ma anche il fatto che questo bambino,
diventato poi ragazzo,
abbia deciso di viverci in Sicilia.
Per molti insomma questi aspetti
rappresentano un'eccezione.
Ma oggi qui con voi vorrei condividere
tre validi motivi,
affinché quella che è solo un'eccezione
possa diventare una regola,
una vera e propria regola di vita.
Il primo motivo per restare
è semplicissimo:
per mantenere la propria identità.
Sono tantissimi i giovani
che sono costretti
a emigrare per motivi lavorativi.
Ovviamente non mi riferisco a coloro
i quali lo fanno per libera scelta,
per gusto personale o per ambizione.
Parlo di chi si sente obbligato a farlo
per paura di non riuscire a realizzarsi.
Certo, viaggiare è meraviglioso:
conoscere nuovi luoghi,
nuove culture, nuove idee...
Ma chi lo fa perché crede
di non avere alternativa
rischia di perdere le proprie radici,
la propria identità.
Io credo fermamente
che questi due aspetti
siano una ricchezza inestimabile
su cui costruire la propria personalità
e da cui partire per creare
qualcosa di nuovo ed eccezionale.
Si dice sempre che il jazz sia nato
dall'incontro di più culture.
Quello che non si dice
è che, insieme ad africani ed ebrei,
sia stata proprio
la tradizione bandistica siciliana
a far nascere questo genere musicale.
Allora io, proprio in onore
e in memoria di queste radici,
che fortunatamente non si sono perse,
voglio suonare per voi
una mia composizione
che si intitola "La banda".
(Musica)
(Applausi)
C'è un altro motivo per cui un giovane
dovrebbe pensare di restare
nella propria terra d'origine:
per cambiare ciò che lo circonda.
Così tante persone parlano di andare via,
emigrare, scappare,
che spesso vediamo chi rimane
come uno sconfitto,
e chi invece va via
come chi ce l'ha fatta.
Io, ovviamente, non sono d'accordo.
Conoscere il mondo può contribuire
a migliorare noi stessi,
ad ampliare i nostri orizzonti;
ma può anche servirci
per migliorare il contesto
da cui proveniamo e in cui viviamo.
Io, per esempio, viaggio moltissimo,
ma poi sento l'esigenza
di fare base in Sicilia
perché ho deciso di coinvolgere
nel mio progetto di vita
anche la mia comunità.
C'è una cosa che mi rende
particolarmente orgoglioso:
il jazz festival della mia città natale,
Vittoria.
Siamo ormai arrivati
alla settima edizione
e il livello è internazionale.
Vi assicuro che da direttore artistico
non potrei essere più fiero
di come il jazz sia diventato ormai
una ricchezza di tutti:
un genere di nicchia,
che pian piano appassiona
sempre più persone.
Ed è proprio con l'invito
a migliorare il contesto che ci circonda,
che voglio suonare per voi
un'altra mia composizione
che ha proprio questo spirito,
che ho scritto ispirandomi
a questo concetto.
Il titolo è: "Recreating".
(Musica)
(Applausi)
Grazie!
Mauro Schiavone!
(Applausi)
C'è un altro motivo per cui
provare a restare è necessario:
spesso chi vorrebbe restare
non lo fa perché teme di sentirsi solo,
ha paura di non essere supportato,
aiutato, sostenuto.
Io credo che non cerchiamo abbastanza:
se facciamo le cose veramente bene
prima o poi ci imbatteremo in qualcuno
che è disposto a mettersi in gioco
al nostro fianco,
ad aiutarci e sostenerci.
Forse dovremmo provare
a cercare meglio vicino a noi,
piuttosto che partire per posti lontani.
A tal proposito credo che a volte
basti dare un buon esempio
per ricevere delle risposte sorprendenti.
Insomma per concludere,
credo che 'restare' e 'non accontentarsi'
possano benissimo andare d'accordo.
È quindi con la speranza
di festeggiare tanti successi
di chi ha avuto il coraggio di restare,
di chi ha il coraggio di restare,
che vi saluto con un'altra
mia composizione,
che s'intitola: "La festa".
(Musica)
(Applausi)